trào mừng tổn bị thư chú tích nước sôn lâm và phung nhân
tổn bị thư chú tích nước tập cận định chúc mừng đồng chi tô lâm với được
có hội hảm ả sấu tín nhận bầu dứt cân viện chú tích nước
và chân trọng việc đồng chi tô lâm tham chung quốc đầu tiên sau thình công rất tốt này
của đại hội Mỹ bốn và Việt Nam hoàn tất kiện toàn trước sang lệnh đạo nhà nước
thế hiện sự coi chọng cao tu tiên hàng đầu của đảng nhà nước Việt Nam
và tổn bị thư chú tích nước có lâm đối với khoan yện hai nước
trong vị thư chú tích nước có lâm chân thành cảm ơn trong vị thư chú tích nước tập cận viện
đã sành cho đoàn đại biểu cấp cao của đảng nhà nước Việt Nam
sự đón tiếp trọng thị chú đau thấm tình đồng chi a ng
và vừa qua đã có nhiều hình thức thế giễn xử vụ mạnh mẽ
đối với đại hội Mỹ bốn của đảng công sang Việt Nam
không báo những định đến mới về liên loạt và thực hiện của đại hội Mỹ bốn
có vị thư chú tích nước có lâm đến mạnh
bàn lạnh đạo đảng nhà nước Việt Nam khoa mới
mong muốn của mạnh lạnh đạo đảng nhà nước Trung Quốc
không gần quân đắp trên thống yếu nghị
thuốc đầy phát hiện đối tác hợp tắt chính lực phản viện
có đồng chi sẽ tương lai Việt Nam chú Quốc có ý nghĩa chính lực
lệ gản thách chiến
2 nhà lệnh đạo Mỹ tỏ phuy bừng trước những ngước thách chiến
tốt nệt của hai đảng hai nước trong vị giản qua
lối bật là cháu đổi chính lực cấp cao diễn ra mật thiết
các cơ chế hợp tắt nệ gản thân viện không phủ tình cây
không biết như chủ tính nước có lâm đến gị hài bên sắc lập tâm có mới
chở tắt tinh tế thơ mại lối tư và zù lịch
khiến thực hả mục tiêu phát triển của mỗi nước
tập trung một lực nâng tâm kích nối hạ tầng trên lực
tâm biết từ chủ tính nước tập cực bình đề gị hài bên thuốc
này vẫn chắc sự nghiệp trả hội chủ nghĩa của mỗi nước
lâm sâu sắc hợp phát trong các nệng ngề sọc biển
tăng cơ hợp tắt chủ et sản xuất và chủ thông ứng
không dính dưới môi trường quốc tế on định cười mở và hợp tắt
mạo về phạm biển khốn định và thịt vực ở khu vực và triển thế giới